a huge part of what I enjoy about life
is the journey and the process yeah you
know and like I'm you know Mariel makes
me happy you know but I'm not gonna lie
there are times when just like I just
want to cut this [ __ ] line and be
free and I'll be real to you even Mary
don't feels like that sometimes yeah cuz
Mariel was a very independent girl yeah
and you're both very independent yeah
and so this stage of us being with each
other all the time is is new for both of
us yeah and you're working it out yeah
and it's normal to have friction a
[ __ ] causes us to clash all the time
and we have to figure this out because I
mean just as an example because we want
to move out of our current place yeah
right and then there was a an argument
that we had that kind of broke you out
because I think it just starts to we
just start to think about all the
negative things that could happen when
we move in together into another place
again it's like oh how are we gonna
decorate this place she wants it a
certain way
I wanted a certain yeah and no matter
what if it goes this way or that way one
of us one of us is gonna be unhappy
simply because we're so hyper
independent and we want things our own
way it just we tend to clash a lot yeah
and it's because she's always done
things how she wanted and because she
lived by herself and something for me
even when I had the when I lived with
roommates
I still got my way and the reason why is
because I paid the most friend uh I pay
the rent I pay the utilities I paid
everything so and I bought the furniture
so it was gonna be my way I just paid
more money for it yeah in this case it
doesn't work whether I pay for it or not
she's still gonna have a [ __ ] say
yeah that's what I found out the woman's
gonna win no matter what I'm [ __ ]
know how they win they just complain to
the point where you can't anymore and
you just don't care anymore yeah hard
man I do when I see when I sometimes I
see you man I'm like look at this
[ __ ] free ass here's like a bundle of
feathers in the wind you just tossed
that [ __ ] somewhere and just [ __ ]
[ __ ] and scatters where it goes and I'm
like that used to be me I used to just
do whatever the [ __ ] I wanted and I said
they should have run Mariel as well you
could you could always leave me if you
want but there's gonna be a shift like
what if you when you guys do figure this
out and then you know you can coexist
there's gonna be a shift where
like if I am single in the next 20 years
right like you're good you guys gonna
obviously have kids you guys are gonna
have like more to look forward to and
when all those things are kind of like
said and done then I'm gonna be the
lonely bastard that's like have anything
to do or people to be with on
Thanksgiving or whatever right yeah so
yeah I think it's just a balance there's
got to be that that in between or if I'm
happy with being alone like my brother
he knows exactly what he wants he's like
I don't [ __ ] like people I already
have enough friends I'm cool and I'm
done well there are a lot of people like
that but I think what when people do get
in happy is when you're trying to meet
an expectation that doesn't really exist
make other people happy you're afraid of
other people talking [ __ ] or whatever I
think that's what drives people into
this like crazy you know place in their
head yeah that's true though when that
[ __ ] happens
you know it's my mom kind of put it like
this cuz you know I kind of just you
know I talked to her a lot yeah and I I
asked her how would you feel if I said
that I didn't want any kids at all yeah
you know I just don't want kids and you
know of course she was kind she kind of
felt a little weird about it but then I
was testing me - yeah
son of a [ __ ] II I want a grandchildren
you kiss okay but she was she said it
says she goes you know the reason why I
think people want to have kids or why
you should have kids is because you're
thinking about yourself right now and
how happy you are without the stress of
having children is because right now you
can find purpose in everything that you
do right so whether you're doing a new
business venture you're working on new
projects that's where your purpose lies
she goes you'll be surprised at towards
the end of your life when you have said
and done majority of things that you
want you you're gonna wonder where
should you place your attention like
where does your hopes and dreams go to
and if you don't have kids a lot of
people feel like your hopes and dreams
dies with everything that you've done
but that's what your kids have and so
you as an old person she goes for me
I don't live for myself in your nah she
goes I'm healthy and I'm happy now
because I I've seen what I've done with
you and I'm living out the rest of my
days to see what happens with you
what makes me excited she goes there's a
point to where you feel lonely she goes
what if what if you you go up and then
your dad dies I still have you yeah I
still have your brother yeah you know
there's always a community to come and
help you out and so that's why I think
it's important to have kids also helps
you grow and learn new things and it's
just it's another chapter in your life I
don't don't picture it as your life
ending but it's a new chapter opening
yeah you know it's just a new story that
begins yeah I've heard that from a lot
of people where it's like one of the
best joys of life is just kids mmm and
I'm like that's [ __ ] awesome thank
god I'm a man dude could be 50 years old
and I could bust a nut yeah I can have a
kid yeah I mean I won't be able to see
them grow as old as maybe if I started
now yeah but yeah I think um I don't
know I mean I think right now it's not
it's just not even a goal of mine to
have a kid yeah having a kid I'm not
gonna lie like I I do want a kid but
having a kid scares me man it scares the
living [ __ ] [ __ ] out of it we were in
Hawaii we saw all of our friends with
kids and it was like holy mother crap
time dug like just watching Bart Gio and
and Christina and how beat up they
[ __ ] look just trying to take I mean
they were having fun too but just to
have a kid wash him off every time he's
at the beach make sure that he's not
running around touching [ __ ] and you
just see how exhausted and tired that
they are that's not me if I go on
vacation [ __ ] those kids they're staying
back at home with my grandpa you're not
coming it's a vacation I'm coming back
looking like I slept yeah cuz even for
us - I gave me was a short trip and I
you know I love having Bart's you and
all them around but it definitely wasn't
the vacation it was supposed to be
because there were kids there yeah so we
have to make adjustments for that as
well and we don't have kids so I can
only imagine what it's like for them
24/7 they can't leave it yeah it's not
like a dog yeah a dog who [ __ ] take
care of himself you just put some food
and they're good to go and I'm like all
right I'll let you go pee yeah like I
think until like the kids maybe like
eight or nine years old yeah then I
might take them traveling cuz before
then I'm trying to deal with that [ __ ]
it's pretty rough yeah man like just
unless that's all you're doing I think
it's because of our lifestyle like we
you know work is all around us 24/7
mm-hmm
you know we don't
separate all this stuff it's all kind of
gray area I don't know if I could give
up my lifestyle right now yeah even
though it's stressful and it's a lot of
work and you travel a lot too oh yeah
give you that out of your system the
moment I have a kid this travel is
cutting out yeah I can't leave Merrill
with the kid alone she'll [ __ ] die
yeah you know she'll suffer from this
[ __ ] so you got to get it out of your
system before you do it I got two years
man where I just got to go to Thailand
and get my dick sucked or something yeah
I mean that's what I'm gonna be doing
now is just traveling so I always hear
the best things about well I don't know
how people feel about this but
prostitution is pretty high in a lot of
these other countries and everybody
tells me really you know that scene in
rush hour I heard that's just like for
real like when the girls come out and
then you make them and you pick them out
I heard that shit's legit legit I've
done that here in America